in many workplaces there are rules that
are completely unspoken understanding
them is crucial for success and yet you
won't find them in your employee
handbook unless you're lucky enough to
have a mentor or manager who pulls you
aside to help you just kind of have to
figure them out on your own
[Music]
starting a new job can feel like
starting at a new school you're meeting
new people you're getting thrown into
unfamiliar situations and you're
constantly wondering what does everyone
think of me but whether you're starting
your first job ever or just starting a
new role making a great impression
doesn't have to be so scary it all comes
down to deciphering those unspoken rules
and demonstrating what I call the three
C's competence commitment and
compatibility the first C is competence
on day one your new colleagues are
probably looking at you and thinking can
you do your job the way to convince
others not to mention yourself that yes
you can is to show your homework and to
give others something to react to let's
say it's your first day and it's utter
chaos people are throwing you messages
with nothing more than a c below at the
top and pulling into meetings without
any notice or context your manager just
gave you a task and two minutes in
you're already confused instead of going
back to them right away and saying I
don't know what to do next help or doing
what I did which is not asking questions
at all think about a similar task that
you tried in a previous job in school or
just for yourself what steps did you
take then
make your best guess and just give it a
try
then go back to your manager and say I'm
working on X and I'm not quite sure of
what to do next
I've taken X steps and spoken to so and
so and I understand this part but I'm
still unclear about this other part what
do you think about this approach no I'm
not suggesting that you fake it till you
make it but what I am suggesting is that
you try until you can't try anymore time
matters though so give yourself a limit
and depending on your deadline figuring
things out on your own
then ask and then learn from what others
tell you it's your first bit of
knowledge around how things work here
the second C is commitment besides
looking to see if you can do your job
your colleagues are also looking to see
if you're dedicated during your first
week in a new job try asking your
manager questions about expectations my
favorites are one what are my top
priorities in this role
two how would you like to communicate
day to day and week to week and three
what have your highest performers done
that you'd suggest that I do too for
your peers try to go more casual in your
first few days your manager will be
probably or well at least hopefully
taking you around and introducing you to
your other teammates in those moments
think about how you can transform some
of those highs into conversations and
then those conversations into
relationships one option is to ask how
others weeks are going for those you
really get along with try involving them
in your work and maybe even your life
with phrases like oh I'd love to get
your input on a or could I get your
advice on B these can all go a long way
in deepening a relationship the third C
is compatibility
every time a new person joins a team the
others on it want to know we get along
with us
by initiating conversations you're
already expressing compatibility
but while you're at it use this time to
try and identify who's in charge of what
or what I call invisible swim Lanes
let's say you've just started a new
remote job
first ask your manager if there's an org
chart it's a diagram showing who reports
to whom
and if there is one amazing but formal
job titles and Reporting lines can only
tell you so much about how things really
work
so when you're in meetings in group
chats pay attention
what's each person's role who reports to
whom who's on whose side who commands
respect which behaviors get rewarded and
which behaviors get punished
understanding these Norms loyalties
power Brokers and swim Lanes is what
people are really referring to when they
say that it's important to understand A
team's culture and by the way while
you're mapping out these swim Lanes look
around to see if there's any swim Lane
that might be unoccupied or in other
words what tasks might be available that
aren't currently being done that can
help your team accomplish more better
faster cheaper safer more securely by
doing this you'll show that you're
competent enough to spot gaps committed
enough to fill them
and compatible enough to not overstep
here's the reality of starting a new job
doing your job is only part of it the
rest is about how you get along with
other people but as much as we've been
talking about others sizing you up
don't forget to do the same is this
environment where you can flourish and
do your best work can you see yourself
getting along with your co-workers is
this even work you're excited to do
every job is a two-way street you can do
well only if you want to do well and if
you're set up to do well
so look around reflect and be honest
with yourself about whether this is a
good place for you